So let's take a look on how to implement
app cache, in our conference application. First, we go
into out HTML file, and we add the manifest.
In our manifest file, we list in the cache
section all of the static resources for our application.
Our javascript files, our CSS, our favicon. All of
the images we need to use. But, note one
file that's missing. Our index.html. Any page that points
to the manifest, that's, that has that magic manifest
equal in the html element, is implicitly cached, which can
very easily got out of control. It's kind of
hard to get them out of the cache once they're
in it. Which is why we're only using the
manifest attribute, on this one page. Note though, in the
NETWORK section, we put the google analytics javascript file
and all the maps api serves. We can't really usefully
cache these API servers. So, we'll have to be
online for now. Now let's go back to our app,
and with the Devtools console open, let's reload and see
what happens. You can see in the console, a whole
bunch of application cache messages. If we go up
to the top of this, you can see it's creating
an application cache based on this file. It checks that,
and then it starts downloading all of the resources that
are inside that manifest. When it completes, it
sends us an event that says the application
cache is cached. Now, if we reload the
page again, we get a much shorter set. This
time it says, the document was loaded from
the application cache. It tells us where the
manifest is. It checks the cache, but there's
no update ready, so it doesn't bother doing anything.